what's a couple of superheroes doing
here at Kapow I'll wait here for the
fans you know now that I've got the new
52 I got my new costume no the fans want
to meet me I've grown a beard as well
that's all we're here and why did he
pick your costumes why Superman and
Spidey we were obsessed with each one we
were wearing I'm obsessed with
spider-man and he's a Superman's biggest
fan on you ma'am I am indeed I spent
months on this thing
girlfriend build a cape for me I spent
months buying this off eBay what is it
about Spidey and superman' that make
them so awesome spider-man's just a
normal bloke I can relate to it because
I wasn't very cool as I was growing up
and he's not really either so he's just
awesome he's the man
and Superman well Steve Meyers just give
me the embodiment of a superhero you
know the ultimate superhero
it's like he's he's the sort of the
symbol of hope and light and everything
good in the world is Superman so and
he's bulletproof and he can run really
fast and he can fly he's got ice breath
and laser eyes dusting the pros there's
minimal cons and he's fantastically
good-looking he's got the best outfit
it's got Cape just any of his photos she
knows what's the favorite bit about
being Spidey and Superman everyone seems
to want to get our picture taken with us
it's fantastic and everybody longer
there walk up as well kids were absent
cuz I didn't have much fun when crossing
the highway up because I was a bit of a
chicken the kids were loving you and
their little kids were getting so
excited about spotting him in a suit
lately I had one little boy come up and
Stroke my arm in the street you get in
the comics to start where there's have
been a lifelong love I'm really dyslexic
so books are just impossible but like
that the pictures draw you in and comics
and I've got in some when I was like
seven or eight my I was walking through
bath and my a spy spider-man in in a
window my nan took me into the shop and
I've just never stopped buying them
since like habit of a lifetime I'm so
happy I did go in and saw some like
yeah well me I actually start off with
manga and anime since I've been in love
with Dragonball since I was about 3
years old and then I've always dabbled
in comic books but it's it's um had been
you know a couple of years ago that he
sort of filled it for me it ruined my
life you might say destroyed me it's
waste so much money every week on comic
that's this grace when so much money a
week about 35 quid a week or something
now they have to start budgeting
properly because that's what we have no
money focus San Diego comic-con spending
that money mode we can be able to go to
San Diego
well guys have a fantastic time it you
look both were fantastic oh seven
costumes enjoy the rest of the day
you